so go to the green new deal what the
green new deal
uh uh is not a bill that it's something
that you know it was 14 pages what it
what are they proposing is their
solution for it so because to me
everything fine let's just say this is
happening what's your solution what's
your approach to fixing this the green
new deal the green new deal looks at
this and it goes back to what i just
said they believe that the earth can't
handle capitalism essentially and
freedom and that we need to have a
socialist system but they know they
could never sell their brand of
socialism i don't know if it's the right
terms anymore especially since covet
it's not really socialism you could you
could argue it's technocracy it's uh
it's a tyranny of uh you know
of uh the of a small elite group of
people but essentially
the green new deal argues
that
that they can't sell their ideas on
their own so they argued that we have a
crisis and that this is the solution in
other words if they had to sell the
green new deal on its own merits it
would have no chance so they use the
climate scare to say this is what's
happening at the climate scare and these
are our solutions and the solutions what
is these what is these it's solutions
okay in my book green fraud i have a
whole chapter on the 1970s ice age scare
and it's eerie how the green new deal
literally mirrors the same solutions to
the ice age scare
sovereignty limiting treaties economic
de-growth uh stopping of meat stock
radical restrictions on freedom of
movement radical restrictions on home
ownership radical restrictions on just
on
on thermostat controls in your house on
the size of your home in other words
it's a micro-regulation of every aspect
of your life they did this in the 1970s
first of all they said that man-made
global cooling
was caused by fossil fuels emitting
aerosols which were blocking the sun
causing global dimming their solutions
were sovereignty limited treating wealth
redistribution uh and and literally the
the same
virtual signaling of the climate in
other words it's the same agenda you can
go back to the overpopulation you can go
back to the the rainforest scares
whatever environmental problem they
always believe the government needs to
step in and micromanage all of freedom
every aspect of our life because people
left alone
will create environmental disasters
racial disasters will create climate
disasters and we need government to
essentially keep a watch over on us and
that's why the green new deal does
everything from your dishwasher to your
washing machine to your control your
home thermostat to your to your
to your diet to your travel to the type
of homes you can buy whether they're
sustainable to the type of car to
eliminating the internal combustion
engine which is gaining
that's a huge issue that's gaining huge
steam but all of this was part of the
green new deal as a framework
importantly though they introduced the
green new deal multiple times but most
recently when biden was first elected
when he was sworn in and you never heard
of it again why is that because they
know even democrats won't support it
it's the same way democrats didn't
support obama's cap and trade force is
not going to work for force is not going
to work and as much as they want to do
it can you pull up this article from
northwestern uh
education.edu the one i just text you
yeah can you make this bigger so i just
pulled up to see what are ways to
stop global warming okay let's see what
they have number one change of light
replacing one regular light bulb with a
compact fluorescent light bulb will save
you 150 pounds of carbon dioxide a year
number two drive less walk by carpool or
take mass transits more often number
three recycle more you can save 2 400
pounds of carbon dioxide per year by
recycling just half of your household
waste number four check your tires
keeping your tires inflated properly can
reduce your gas mileage by more than
three percent every gallon okay so far
nothing is forced i'm okay with any of
these so far yeah use less hot water it
takes a lot of okay fine avoid products
with a lot of packaging
you know okay fine adjust your
thermostat move your thermostat down
just two degrees in winter and up two
degrees in summer could save you 2000
pounds of carbon dioxide a year okay
whatever plant a tree single tree can
will absorb one
ton of carbon dioxide over its lifetime
and last one turn off electric
electronic devices simply turning off
your television individuals oh cool i
find it's a dvd player that's what we
used to watch it's the same list they
would have given you in the 1970s but
what i'm saying is the following okay
bill nye said the year i was born
america the world had 2.99 billion
people living there 3 billion people
living there today it's at and a half
billion people okay
so then you go and you say everything's
linked to
the
growth of population seven and a half
billion people okay then you'll hear the
word being thrown thrown around where
even gates said this in 2011 i want to
say cnn when he was talking to is it
gupta not group they was talking to the
doctor that was on joe rogan what's the
guy that's
okay yeah yeah he's talking to gupta
they're talking about you know
depopulation right okay so if they're
saying the problem is
really serious okay so
you know so then the solution becomes
you need to go from seven and a half
billion eight billion back to one
billion so what do you wanna do about it
do you really wanna fix it that way
because that seems to be the only
solution because what okay so then let's
let's just say you can't have that many
babies you know you know like china deal
and china went back to the one baby deal
and now they're back down to back up to
like listen we need to have some babies
because we've slowed down and average
age is now 38.4 and we got india's at
26. we got to compete we got old people
we got to have more babies so what is
really the solution because the solution
i'm hearing about
is either more control
you know at least you look at what
tesla's doing what what elon musk is
doing right credit to him by the way to
give him credit on what he said even
though he said that six years ago the
video i played the the what i read about
what he said yeah he said this october
18th of 2021 what i'm about to read to
you he said if you ask any scientist
are you sure that human activity is
causing global warming
any scientists should say no
this is elon musk because you cannot be
sure
let's say hypothetically co2 was good
for the environment and let's say
hypothetically the united states
possessed all the oil in the world well
you'd still have to get off oil because
it's a it's a finite resource and as you
start to run out of it the scarcity
would drive the cost up and cause
economic collapse it's just i just don't
understand why we'd run that experiment
particularly when at you when you
considered that at some point we have to
get to something that is sustainable we
have to have sustainable production of
energy and consumption of energy because
uh tautology tautologically
it is is that the word by the way
logically how do you what does that word
mean by the way it's
it's like you guys are using big
esl over here right tell me what that do
you know what that word is that earlier
it's like a double meaning topologically
it's redundant okay because
tautologically if it's unsustainable you
will run out of it so even he is saying
that's that's a that was that's a that's
a shift
seven months ago that's one thing yeah
the first part of that yeah the second
part okay
i in the book i detail in my research i
went back johnny carson's show is a
great source for people like paul
ehrlich who was a celebrity he was like
the al gore of his day on overpopulation
well in 1980
well first of all in the 1960s he warned
of the same thing peak oil resource
scarcity we're going to have famines
we're going to have massive population
uh disruption because we're going to run
out of all these fuels he lamented
people hopping in their car driving to
the grocery store getting a six-pack
this is all paul ehrlich he predicted
the end of oil within 10 years in 1980.
there's been people predicting the end
of oil for decades i think it's at least
since the 1930s 40s maybe earlier
the problem with what elon musk said and
there's not i mean
if
if solar wind first of all solar and
wind last count 2020 or less than four
percent of the u.s energy production
we're still about 79 fossil fuels if you
go back 100 years we're about 80 fossils
same with global not much has changed
so
there is no chance people thought we
were going to run out of natural gas or
didn't think natural gas was that
plentiful where is it we can't get it we
found a new way or they revised and they
improved upon an old way fracking
hydraulic fracking we ended up in that
this is in my book i think it was 2009
energy information agency made
projections
not a single prediction was right about
the trajectory of co2 emissions because
the united states led the world in our
reduction that little chart the little
video animation you showed showed our
rapid and that was because we switched
from coal to natural gas
a better technique was able to extract
it so there's no way people
can predict that when fossil fuel will
run out having said that
when you're powering a modern economy
you don't ban energy that's plentiful
now and available and there's probably
who knows with new technology
oil and gas could go for
thousands of years hundreds of years who
knows how many years but you always know
100 years ago
200 years ago technology's always
changing you can never predict the
energy mix the problem with the whole
climate agenda problem with what elon
musk said
he's trying to use subsidies government
regulations and bans on certain
industries and to promote some and ban
others which means you're going to be
shutting down one and forcing us to go
to another they're going after the
internal combustion engine the world
bank
nicholas stern former president at world
bank meeting a couple weeks ago wants to
stop the world bank financing of
institutions organizations 2030 2035.
that's huge yes i mean you can't like
that you can't just say oh yeah i'm not
going to give up my suv you're not going
to have a choice when chrysler ford and
all the automakers aren't going to be
able to get financing to even make it
that's point one but then point two of
course
and this is where i still waiting for
the woke uh the i shouldn't say woke but
the the newly woke to skepticism uh both
i'm waiting for rfk junior and elon musk
to come out and address this
naomi wolfe already has she's condemned
the green new deal is fascist uh but i'm
waiting to hear rfk junior and elon musk
start condemning some of their previous
positions on climate they haven't done
it but i do i do sense a shift in elon
musk but essentially
you use what you have until you have
something to replace it and that's the
biggest complaint when people can go to
walmart and buy a solar panel put it on
the roof and get off the grid that's the
day you don't need to have this silly
argument but in the meantime you're
allowing bureaucratic bean counters
politicians lobbyists and big
corporations to determine every aspect
and say we got to get rid of this this
kind of car your dishwasher is going to
have to run for three hours we're going
to have a thermostat control on your
home because we don't want you to you
know put the air conditioner too high
we're going to have carbon ration cars
and then you get into this whole
post covert dystopian world which i'd
like to talk about i'd like to talk
about at some point because that's
changed the entire climate debate it's a
quaint discussion to sit here and talk
about the green new deal it's really
irrelevant at this point it's probably
never going to be voted on in congress
it's being implemented as we speak
in every agency of the biden
administration through financing through
the bureaucracy through executive orders
but more importantly climate is no
longer the issue it was it is now a
literally a uh it's been it's been
consumed by covid climate is a
supporting player now you uncheck
climate change leads to unchecked covid
if you don't support green new deal
you're a grandma killer but it's all
about climate causing more uh covert
sorry climate causing more viruses
because people don't care
they tried for decades to get people
scared on climate they failed according
to pew harris
gallup polling a virus comes along cut
across ideological lines terrified them
and then the climate activists said
everything we're doing for covid we
should have been doing for climate and
now harvard public health journal nature
they're all saying
uncheck climate change leads to more
viruses so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]